Oh, good morning, Mr. Blake,
I'm Amy, your new secretary.
Hello, Amy,
good to meet you.
Say, I'm very busy today
so I'd like you to make sure
that I'm not disturbed.
No one, but no one,
is to go into my office
without an appointment,
got it?
Yes, sir.
Thanks, doll.
I need to see
Mr. Blake immediately!
Oh, I'm sorry, sir.
He's busy right now.
Well, this can't wait.
No, no, you can't
go in there!
(man)
Blake! Completely
unacceptable.
Third time this month!
I'm sorry, Mr. Blake, I told
him he can't come in here!
All right, Amy,
have a seat, Bill.
For the love of God.
This is--
Damn it, Amy, what
happened there?
I'm sorry, sir.
I told him he
couldn't go in there.
Okay.
Well, I really need you to put
some oomph into it, kiddo.
Okay.
All right.
This is an abomination,
I need to see Mr. Blake.
No, you can't go
in there!
The hell I can't.
Blake, I've had
it up to here!
I'm sorry, Mr. Blake, I told
he can't come in here!
(Mr. Blake)
Jesus Christ, Amy.
Ed, did she say you
couldn't come in here?
Yes, she did.
Well, how did
she say it?
Uh, "You can't go
in there."
Okay, that's
pretty good.
But the way she said it, it
felt like I could go in there.
(Mr. Blake)
Mm-hmm.
Amy, there are thousands
of women who'd kill for the
opportunity to tell people they
can't come into my office.
I know, I'm sorry, sir,
I'll work on it.
Mm-hmm, all right,
have a seat, Ed.
You can't go in there,
you can't go in there.
You can't go in there.
I have to see Mr. Blake!
No, no, you
can't go in there!
Oh.
Okay, thank you.
I'll wait.
Oh.
Well, I'm sorry I yelled,
I have to say that.
No, I respect the
American secretary.
I'm not an animal.
Sir, thank you.
Today's been so
difficult for me and--
Say! Is someone
going in there?
Where?
Come on, everyone!
What? No!
No, you can't
go in there!
You can't go in there!
You, you can't
go in there!
You can't go in there!
You can't go
in there!
You can't-- Oh, gosh,
I'm dreadful at this.
(Mr. Blake)
How did you guys
get in here?
Amy!
Look, Amy, you're a woman
and you can only focus
on one thing at
a time, I get that.
That's why I gave you
just the one task.
In fact, what are
you even doing typing?
Look, you need to start doing
your job or I'm going to find
someone who can
do your job.
(sputters)
Well, hello, I'm here
to see Mr. Blake.
You can't go in there!
Oh!
Ooh! Ow!
(woman)
I'm sorry, your call cannot
be completed as dialed.
You! Can't!
Go! In! There!
(Mr. Blake)
Amy.
Did my 11:30
get here yet?
Mr. Blake will
see you now.
♪ Stand up, stand up
♪ And be proud
let someone in ♪
♪ Let someone in